he's Patrick Ewing the Georgetown head
coach a hall-of-famer remember the dream
team and boy he can't wait to tell you
all the great things about the Jordan
documentary Patrick where do we start
talking about all the wonderful things
about Michael Jordan I live through him
you know all the battles that we had to
go through and now y'all have documented
like you don't have to keep in a rubbing
it in my face
are you watching I want some of it when
I watch some you know I watch the little
Dan I shut it off and go do other things
I gotta say you know his if I lived
through it I don't need to watch I know
he's great
were you interviewed for it yes I was
and what did they ask you about they
asked me a million questions you know
well III think they might have sold me
on it a small small piece of it but I
think that they interviewed me for about
an hour I think you're coming up I think
you and Reggie Miller are gonna get some
air time coming up I I told you this
yesterday when I talk to Reggie a couple
of weeks ago I get still painful for him
he hated he hated talking about it and
the only reason why he watched the
documentaries because I said hey were
you watch it so we can talk about it he
said it's no fun
he said fun for you guys because you get
to watch it go all Michael Jordan so
great you know it was painful for us oh
definitely you know as fans you know
people are you know all in awe of him
but we're the ones that had to battle
them and every and you can't as a
competitor you can't think of him as you
know this Michael Jordan one of the
greatest players to ever play the game
you're out there trying to kick his butt
and you and your team is trying to do
everything possible to try to to try to
beat that team is there a you know I
look back there's a clip where Mike's
last trip to the garden and is it after
the game where he said something but I
haven't handed out this kind of beating
since 1984 when he was talking about the
title game with you and North Carolina
Georgetown
so it went even that either wasn't even
a beating we had an opportunity to win
to win that game we just you know like
every game it's all about mistakes and
we made a crucial mistake at the you
know the last possession turned the ball
over and they steal the game but you
know that's just Michael he's he's a
great guy he's been he's a friend but
he's the biggest trash talker that I've
ever met but both he and bird but when
did he become a friend because you know
the Bulls in next you guys had real
battles but when did you when do you
become a friend of Jordans well you know
I think we've been friends ever since we
met each other on our visit on my visit
to North Carolina he is already he had
already committed that was the first
time I met him and you know we just
develop a friendship since then we we
played in the McDonald's game together
spend some times then and then over the
years you know our friendship grew we
both were represented by the same we had
the same agents both Dean Smith and
coach Thomas or great friends so I think
all of those things you know created he
gave us history how close were you to go
into North Carolina
you know I imagined that team you know
money when I look back at it you know if
I had gone there it would have been me
myself Michael worthy Perkins that was
been a hell of a front line oh my good
but you know I made the right decision I
went there I I didn't like it as much as
I thought I would have so I chose to go
else and you know it's funny because
Dean Smith told me if you're not coming
if you're not gonna come to North
Carolina you should go to Georgetown so
I listened to him yeah good advice there
we're talking to Patrick Ewing the Hall
of Famer Georgetown's head coach member
of the dream team do you know why Isaiah
wasn't on the dream team no I don't make
but you might everybody has everybody
you know everybody you know has one
thought or another you know I didn't
worry about it either it was a great
player and possibly should have been on
the team but you know I don't get into
all that positive politics I always what
I heard and and these are reliable
people that I heard it from is that you
know Michael wanted an atmosphere that
was fun you knew you were gonna win you
knew you were gonna win the gold medal
Michael and everybody they wanted to
have fun Mike wanted to play golf and
you know play cards and be with his guys
and Isaiah was not part of that
fraternity you know that this wasn't a
basketball decision I could have played
point guard for you Patrick
this this wasn't about hey if we have
Isaiah we're gonna win by 67 over Angola
it was just I think it was about friends
getting together and that was the
feeling I always had to me all about
showing the world our dominance we had
lost in the previous Olympics I remember
we lost two to Brazil and I remember I
forgot the young man's name is yet you
know are yelling at the TV god bless
america
so you know we we were to seal we were
the 18 that the Americas sent to go kick
butt and take names and bring and show
the world the dominance that we have it
in terms of basketball and because of
that because of you know we were like
rock stars everywhere in the world
all those guys or all those kids that
were playing soccer they fell in love
with basketball you're not touching the
I say anything I get it my mother raised
me right no no I got it I got it I got
it I just being a journalist oh do what
do you remember about that practice
where Michael and magic kind of going at
each other and then Michael said there's
a new sheriff in town
oh I remember vividly uh you know those
two always talking trash to each other
you know my magic wanted to make sure
that Michael knew that
he still had game and he you know he had
to go through him to him to get the
throne and Michael was you know of
course as Michael had always had a chip
on his shoulder he wanted to show him
and the rest of the guys that he is the
big dog so you know the practices were
were the were the best thing best games
you know in terms of the games against
other country it was it was it was a
piece of cake but going to the games
against each other when everyone is
trying to you know impress our coworkers
those were those were the games declined
Drexler show up with two left shoes to
practice one time at the drink 10 no no
I'm just asking
I was just I told people this story
yesterday that Michael was so rough on
Clyde Drexler because somebody had the
audacity to say Clyde was as good as
Michael or Michael you know that
competition that they had in the NBA
Finals and I said there was a story that
Clyde showed up with two left shoes for
practice well quite is the great guy
it's a great competitor but and you know
Michael anybody who is uh you know
Michael view as our people view as
somebody that's close to Michael he
tries to do everything he can to
demoralize them or to you know show them
that he is he is number one it plays
these mind games with with guys and I
think that both he and Charles were
trying to play mind games with with with
cry did Clyde show up with two left
shoes for practice bounces did you keep
what did you keep from the dream team um
I well obviously my mettle yeah you know
I have my medal I had I have to shoot
but I moved so many times I see and find
everything I have the medal but it's
funny because I had lost my medals
because you know there was nine
and I moved so many times I blow I
couldn't find both of my gold medal oh
boy and you know I was able to to get a
ban I think my house got broken in New
York at one point I think they state
stolen they stole my medal so I was able
to I call the Jerry Colangelo and it was
great to be able to you know get me to 2
replacement medals so I have my medals
and I have my uniform and apart from
that I think everything is in storage
somewhere had you ever talked about
losing your medals somebody's stealing
your medals before I had not heard that
no this is the first time and Oh Jerry
Jerry you know Jerry I spoke to because
I had to get you know replacement medals
but yeah it's the first time that I
really spoke about it did they take
other memorabilia no they took those
they did to take my championship ring my
college championship ring but someone
tried to sell it on eBay and I was able
to get that back and that sucks yeah
sometimes it's tough to be well-known
oh my goodness yeah I'd never I never
heard that story but you know thank God
Jerry Colangelo was able to get
replacement medals for you and yes he
took care great guy are you gonna watch
if you know you're going to be on the
documentary are you gonna watch the
episode I might watch it little to turn
it back oh look it's like I said I you
know I don't I don't need to watch it to
know what he did or you know how they
beat us you know I think it's great for
the young generation to see how dominant
he was but I mean everyone is I don't
even need to watch it every time
something comes on it's on and I'm
always getting a text you're on oh yeah
I might I might try to start to use this
as recruiting is funny because one of
there's a recruiter a young man that we
you know it's coming to Georgetown and I
he asked me who I thought was was the
better player
you know Michael or LeBron and I told
him Michael so now
texting me like coach I see what you
told me about it Michael wasn't he
wasn't B but are your children asking
you about Jordan my son it's funny I was
before I got on the call he was I was on
his unko but it's with his first grade
class and you know he's not really into
basketball yet but I was I was on the
phone with Michael a couple of weeks ago
and he's like dad is that Michael Jordan
the guy that's on my shirt
I said yes that can he's like can I say
hi I said no Mike Mike trash talk to
your son you're the best you're the best
I did tell the story when we first met
in San Antonio when Mark Jackson put me
on the spot and said hey tell Patrick
who you would take either him or a
Cayman I said a team and then you let
out the biggest laugh and I think you
even said I might take him to a team was
a great player we had a lot of battles
we were very similar
unfortunately he the only time that I
was able to play in the championship and
finals I lost to him but I guess he was
getting me back for us beating judges
and Roger Houston Cougars in 84 yeah Phi
Slama JAMA yes but you know my mark did
put you on on on slash but you know the
funny thing in those and that's the that
was the first time that you and I really
sat down and got to know each other as
people before I just thought of you one
of those media guys ya know it day I I
came away from that dinner and I thank
Mark Jackson I said look I'm glad you
put me on the spot cuz I and you even
said look I appreciate you you know tell
him being honest with me right to my
face because before that dinner I always
loved matumbo more than you but after
that dinner it was it was you Patrick
oh if people only knew the real
personality you have you hid that so
well for so many years and I went to
mark Jackson I said I'll be damned he is
funny with his sense of humor he goes
yeah he doesn't want you to know that
stuff so don't tell people and I went
sorry you know and people when people
see me or they or they judge what they
see on TV they see me with my game face
on my scowl you know I'm playing I'm
sweating
you know I'm giving elbow with every now
and then so you know they when they when
they make judgments on what they see on
TV but you know they sometimes they
never try to get to know what what the
person really is off the court good
stuff great to talk to you and go [ __ ]
and I'll talk to you so that's Patrick
Ewing